we will now study what happens when we
merge independent Poisson processes the
story as well as the final conclusion is
going to be similar to what happened for
the case where we merge independent
Bernoulli processes in particular we
will see that the merged process will
also be Poisson what is the story
suppose that you have two light bulbs
one of them is red and flashes at random
times that are described according to a
Poisson process with a certain rate
lambda 1 the other light bulb is green
flashes also is a Poisson process with a
certain rate furthermore we assume that
the two light bulbs are independent of
each other if you are colorblind so that
the only thing that you see is flashes
but without being able to tell the
caller what kind of process are you
going to see well you will see a Poisson
process also and at this point you can
probably guess what the arrival rate is
going to be for this Poisson process it
should be the sum of these two arrival
rates of the processes that you started
with so this will be our final
conclusion but we want to verify that
this is indeed the correct conclusion so
let us look at the situation in some
more detail we have the two processes
two arrival processes the red one and
the green one and the merged process is
formed by recording an arrival at any
time where either of the two processes
that you started with records an arrival
let us now look at the time interval and
think about the number of arrivals in
the merged process during this time
interval what is that number that number
is equal to the number of arrivals that
you have in the first process plus the
number of arrivals that you have in the
second process let's call that let's
call those numbers and 1 and n 2 so that
what we have here is n
1 plus n 2 now n 1 is a Poisson random
variable because this is a Poisson
process similarly n 2 is a Poisson
random variable we assumed that these
two processes are independent therefore
n 1 plus n 2 is the sum of independent
Poisson random variables and therefore n
1 plus n 2 is also a Poisson random
variable this is reassuring it's a good
piece of evidence that the blue process
is a Poisson process but this is not
enough to argue that it is a Poisson
process we need to check the defining
properties of a Poisson process one
defining property is the independence
property if we take disjoint intervals
the number of arrivals here is
independent or should be independent
from the number of arrivals there the
argument here is exactly the same as for
the Bernoulli case so we will not go
through it in any detail we we just
notice that whatever happens during that
time has to do with whatever happens
during those times in the two processes
that we started with and similarly what
happens in these times has to do with
what happens in these two processes
during those times because for each one
of the two processes that we start with
we have the Poisson assumption so that
this interval is independent from that
interval in the sense that arrivals here
and arrivals they are independent so
because of this whatever happens during
those times has nothing to do with
whatever happens in those times so
number of arrivals here is independent
from the number of arrivals there the
other property that we need to check is
that the probability of recording an
arrival during a small time interval of
length Delta that this probability has
the right scaling properties that it is
linear in Delta in the length of this
interval and that the probability of two
or more arrivals here is negligible to
see what happens during a typical
interval on the merged process we need
to consider what is going to happen
during that typical interval in the
other two processes and consider all the
possible combinations
during a little interval the read
process is going to have zero arrivals
with this probability one arrival with
this probability and two or more
arrivals with this probability which is
negligible actually here we're ignoring
terms of order Delta squared these are
the correct expressions if we only focus
on terms that are either constant or
linear in Delta we are ignoring terms
that are of order Delta square or higher
and similarly for the green process we
have these probabilities for the number
of arrivals that may happen during a
small interval for the merged process we
will have zero arrivals if and only if
we have zero arrivals in the read
process and zero arrivals in the green
process the probability of these two
events happening because we assume that
the two processes that we started with
are independent is going to be the
product of the probabilities of zero
arrivals in one process times zero
arrivals in the other process we
multiply those two terms and if we throw
away the term Delta squared which is
negligible we see that this event is
going to happen with probability 1 minus
lambda 1 plus lambda 2 times Delta
what's the probability that we get one
arrival this is an event that can happen
in two ways we could have one arrival in
the red process and zero arrivals in the
green process and this combination
happens with this probability
alternatively we could have one arrival
in the green process and zero arrivals
in the red process this is this event
and it happens with this probability
having one arrival in the blue process
can happen either this way or that way
so the probability of one arrival will
be the sum of these two probabilities
and if we throw away terms that are
order of Delta squared what we're left
with
is just lambda 1 plus lambda 2 times
Delta finally there's the possibility
that the blue process is going to have
two or more arrivals this happens if we
have one red and one green arrival which
happens with this probability or if any
one of the processes has two or more
arrivals which would be terms here here
and these would be the scenarios but we
notice that each one of these scenarios
has probability that order of Delta
squared this term also has probability
of order Delta squared
so overall the possibility that the blue
process has two or more arrivals this is
something that has probability that of
order Delta squared so during a typical
small interval there is probability
proportional to the length of the
interval of having one arrival and
lambda 1 plus lambda 2 is the factor of
this proportionality and the remaining
probability is assigned to the event
that there are zero arrivals there is
essentially negligible probability of
having two or more arrivals but this
together with independence assumption is
exactly what comes in the definition of
a Poisson process with an arrival rate
equal to this number and so we have
established that the merged process is a
Poisson process whose rate is the sum of
the rates of the processes that we
started from